hi there it's day 28
so that's a month four weeks uh february
has 28 days
uh i'm pretty close to the third way
point
today i want to answer or produce a
video in response to a question i got
from radco my friend in bratislava and
he said how do you deal with sort of
overload and i guess it relates to
burnout
and those kinds of feelings that we can
easily get when we're learning a
language
so
first of all i don't normally go three
hours a day as i'm trying to do now
uh when i was studying for chinese i
would go five six hours a day because i
was that was my job i was working for
the canadian government i was a diplomat
i was sent to hong kong to learn chinese
that's all i did
uh i didn't have a family
i didn't have other obligations i mean
here you know with with my interest in
sports and and dropping in on the office
and so forth three hours three hours and
a bit
uh if i get that in i'm doing pretty
well
however i mean there are times when i
sit down here with my handy dandy ipad
and either i'm reading something or i'm
listening to something or i'm going
through the uh
the flash cards and it seems as if i'm
not getting anywhere
and there are times when i say oh geez i
just don't want to do this anymore
um a because it's a lot to spend
a lot of time and you just don't notice
the results sometimes so so what do you
do
well a number of things
first of all
uh i try to vary my activities as much
as possible so i can read i can listen i
can read and listen at the same time
um
i can do flash cards
um
i can listen to
easy stuff assimil certainly the first
part of assimil
i can read in a book i can read on my
ipad i can read on the computer
uh i have my
chats now with my uh via skype with my
tutors
which amounts to
i don't know perhaps so far it's been
about three to four percent of my
activity i'm going to step it up
um
so varying it is good another thing is i
don't put unnecessary pressure on myself
like i think i said at the beginning
that i would attempt the topic test of
proficiency in korean
language proficiency test i've decided
i'm not going to do that
i don't need it
i've never t the only time i took a
language proficiency test was for
chinese when the government was paying
and they wanted proof that i had
completed a certain
you know course of study
but in all the other languages that i've
learned and i'm up to you know i'm
working on number 13 or 14 here i never
take
tests it doesn't matter to me i learn
the language for myself i learn the
language for the pleasure of
communicating with people reading of
listening of interacting with the
culture the language
that's all that's good enough however
good i am is good enough so
no pressure here in these three months
whatever i achieve i will achieve i will
improve there's no way i'm gonna get
worse so if i improve i'm happy so i
don't put this extra pressure and i've
seen people uh in fact the the genesis
of link came from a guy a chinese
immigrant that we hired who had a high
score in toeic or toefl one of those two
i think it was toeic and whose english
was terrible and i've met lots of people
here who have high scores on some of
these proficiency tests and who don't
speak very well
if i read the definition for example of
this
european
common framework of reference of a c2 c1
b2
so forth i mean
c two is extremely high a lot of people
who claim to have passed these tests c1
c2 i mean they're not when i listen to
them they're fine they're okay but
they're not
uh
you know how they don't use the language
as is described in these definitions
so
and the other thing too is like
uh in every language that i know i'm
gonna be stronger in some aspects
stronger and maybe in those aspects that
matter the most to me maybe i i listen
and understand better i read better
maybe i can communicate okay but i make
lots of grammatical mistakes but maybe
that's good enough for me maybe that's
how i like my language to be i don't
want or need to be judged by a third
party so i don't put that pressure on
myself so i do what i like to do
i do it when i like to do it
um and if i was really fed up i wouldn't
do it but i have to admit i have this
pressure on me because it's the 90-day
challenge i got to try to put in the
time
i know from experience that if i put in
the time i will see the results so
that's the other thing i'm confident
that if i just put in the time
i will get there so i don't i'm not
you know demanding of myself you know
why aren't you doing better none of that
so uh
and i try to get to uh you know
activities that are gonna be enjoyable
at first it's difficult i have to admit
i'm still struggling to understand what
i would call meaningful content
in korean whereas non-meaningful
artificial learner play content i can
understand but the real stuff still very
difficult it's kind of frustrating i
keep hitting it day after day but
i don't mind
because i know that the reward will be
there
and the reward will be that i'm much
better not necessarily that i've
achieved some tremendous uh you know
level
so you know i think that's it don't put
pressure on yourself if you're really
fed up don't do it have a variety of
different ways that you can interact
with the language
um
basically that's it so yeah i don't
i haven't burned out yet
although i have to admit if it weren't
for the 90-day challenge i would be
giving myself days off
and that reminds me i'm at right near
the top of the list in terms of activity
index here at link in this 90-day
challenge i don't like that i would like
to be in the middle of the pack
i hope other people will pick up the
pace
so that at the end of it all we can all
report on how much we improved
so
there you have it that's my take on on
overload or burnout i hope radco this uh